en busca del sueño americano cientos de
emigrantes en su mayoría hondureños y
nicaragüenses partir hacia eeuu en la
primera caravana de 2022 en las redes
sociales está diciendo de que va a haber
un gran gran apoyo de las instituciones
como decirte mire que los senadores
dijeron y se reunieron y dieron una
carta dirigida al presidente by day y
dijeron de que supuestamente no iba a
dar un tal cese de pss no se coman para
darnos la oportunidad de entrar para
buscar cómo trabajar allá para nuestra
familia hombres mujeres y niños son
impulsados a salir de sus países debido
a la falta de empleo y la inseguridad
todos los países del mundo estamos
pasando necesidades pero creemos de que
de que allá en eeuu pues lo pensamos
llegar a un mejor futuro para nuestra
familia ya mis hijos allá los migrantes
continúan su caminata a pesar de que el
gobierno estadounidense los ha instado
en repetidas ocasiones a no intentar
cruzar hacia su país ya que no hay por
el momento una política migratoria
establecida de hecho a partir de enero
la justicia obligó a bailén a
restablecer el programa quédate en
méxico creado por su antecesor donald
trump y que obliga a los solicitantes de
asilo permanecer en este país mientras
se soluciona su situación jurídica es
por esto que algunos optan por buscar
visados en mexico en 2021 131 mil 448
personas solicitaron asilo según la
comisión mexicana de ayuda a refugiados